monty where has it all gone wrong in
your view
well i think england just haven't scored
enough runs and that's been an issue
throughout the whole series it's been
you know an absolute you know diabolical
performance from the england team and
you kind of felt that they would have
shown a bit more fight um but this
dominant performance by the australian
team you know that relentless the line
and length that they're bowling and you
know even though
scott bowlen who you know just is is
it's easy to bring in a new player in a
successful team and he's just been
evolved magnificently well this you know
on the third day where his line of
length was you know just spot on that
sort of you know six to eight meter
length and the unfortunately the england
batsman just didn't have any answer and
they were edging every ball and
it's uh it's you know they need to find
a way of competing in the next two test
matches and the only way they're going
to do that is is to actually score some
runs and find a way of how to score you
know
sort of up to 200 300 you know i think i
get to that sort of level that would be
i think
a really good achievement for them but
uh at the moment you know it's just you
know it's been such a disappointing
performance from from this england team
some of the big questions being asked is
whether there's too much focus on other
formats and also whether these coded
restrictions have been too grueling i
think i had this morning 14 days of
quarantine for 12 days of test cricket
yeah well there's some strict measures
that you know the australian you know
sort of government you know put in place
um i think it comes down to more um that
the pitches in county cricket you know
we've seen the 100 been a huge success
and it's been lucrative for the ecb and
every county team gets allocated 1.3
million you know pounds and part of that
they should invest in i think flatter
pitches so the county game you know the
games are going into the fourth day and
and that's what we need to see we need
to see you know young batsmen learning
how to bat long periods so they they can
then take that into the test stage and
at the moment we're just seeing too many
games you know finishing in in two and a
half days a typical performance will be
seen in the third test match is actually
what happens quite regularly in county
cricket so
i think that could be one area where you
know the ecb may need to look into and
think like how can we you know prolong
you know the county matches and going
into the third or the fourth day and one
way of doing that is actually investing
in um in groundsman and equipment and
and using some of that money to produce
you know flatter wickets
questions already being asked this
morning about joe root's captaincy he's
still england's top scorer but can you
see him continuing as england captain
well it depends
we'll see how how the next two test
matches england perform if they are able
to compete and you know from the bowling
department i think you know jimmy
anderson you know leads that that sort
of bowling attack and i was probably on
you know on par pulling them out for 267
so it's the batting again and if if they
continue to perform like they are um i
think joe root may decide that you know
he may not want to you know continue
captaincy but i think he should continue
until the home series in england there
isn't a really ready-made replacement
for joeru he's done remarkably well you
know being only the third batsman to
score 1700 runs in a calendar year and i
think he should continue to be the
england captain regardless of the next
results in the last two test matches
until the home series in england
thank you very much